I like went on a date once and it was
when I was 13
Billy Eilish is dishing on dating and
get this her first and only date was
only four years ago which makes sense
since she's only 17 it was what movie um
I have no idea and it was the day before
Valentine's Day and then he he kissed me
and then he said that was not as magical
as I thought it was gonna be I mean who
says that after our first kiss that was
not as magical as I thought it was gonna
be bet that guy is regretting this now
oh my god it's unbelievable and also you
get is hella ugly now you know what good
always a silver lining but also guys it
gets even weirder he was super rich and
is his Butler literally his Butler was
there the entire time but in a different
movie theater and he took him and he
left and I was stuck there no one told
me that they were like gonna leave and
and then yeah he left her there alone
again Billy is only 17 she just recently
got her driver's license my parallel
parking is actually fantastic I'm a I'm
good I'm very good okay I love right I'm
very good she turns 18 in December and
she's already thinking about the big day
what will this birthday party look like
and I've been trying to think of it for
months okay
a teen has been like the age I've always
wanted to be my entire life there it is
yeah I have something in mind okay but
okay dude is it like a themed is it a
costume party cuz I love a costume back
to Howard Stern though Billy also talked
to him about how she'll follow up the
success of bad guy and this album and
revealed something kind of interesting I
think mainly I don't know what people
want anymore because I thought that
everyone would hate bad guy and that
everyone would hate when the party's
over
so I don't know what to expect and bad
guy might be my favorite song that you
do I love that song
I mean was she serious
duh I think we can all agree that song
is perfection and also that Billy is
only going to get bigger and bigger are
you ready for the next level of
superstardom no no I think I am honestly
no I think I I feel like I feel like I
am feel like I always have been a little
bit without really realizing it your
destiny that's it for today for all the
latest on Billy's stick with all things
et until next time I'm Katie Krause and
bye for now
[Music]